so you want to land a data science job
but maybe you're wondering how
keep watching and i'll give you some
tips to help you land that dream job
i'm richard and this is richard on data
[Music]
so i've received a number of requests
understandably so
asking how to land that sweet data
science job
or even just how to pass an interview
and i'm gonna give you
five tips to land that job but i am just
gonna focus here on your standard
run-of-the-mill data science job so
we're not focusing here on the fangs of
the world that is facebook apple
amazon netflix and google these
strategies
are going to help you if you're
interested in one of those roles
but those positions and interviews tend
to be of a little bit of a different
caliber
so the strategies for those types of
jobs are going to be a bit different
before we do that maybe you're new here
and you're asking yourself
who's this richard guy and what
qualification does he have to tell me
how to get a job
and that would be a totally fair
question so i've been the one on the
other side of the table
meaning i've interviewed people for
internships and for full-time positions
before
and i've also had to switch jobs a
couple times over the last few years
and every time i actually didn't apply
for that many jobs
but i think out of the jobs that i did
apply to i had a pretty good rate of
landing interviews
and eventually converting those
interviews into offers
except for google i applied there a
couple years ago
and i made it all the way to the last
round and then i got absolutely
destroyed but let's not talk about that
last time i was actively in the job
market i did get three offers in just
over a couple months
and one of those months was december
which is a pretty slow
time for recruitment in general granted
all of that was before the economic
recession that happened here in the
united states
but it was also in the greater detroit
area which is
not the best area in the world for data
science jobs right now
but also far from the worst too so the
tips i'm going to give you in this video
are all things that have worked for me
and luckily
none of them should cost you a dime
before i get into these tips just a few
things that i ask of you guys
number one subscribe to my channel if
you haven't already
number two smash the like button to this
video because that really does help my
content reach a larger audience
also i do have a link in the description
of this video to my patreon account
so if you guys are willing to support me
that way it would be greatly appreciated
alright so my first tip is probably
going to be somewhat counter-intuitive
but my first piece of advice would be to
apply to fewer jobs
now why would i suggest that well i
really do think a lot of people
just make the mistake of applying to way
too many jobs
and after a certain point it just
becomes counterproductive
because there's no way that you're going
to be able to effectively keep track of
that many different people
and that many different companies quite
frankly you're just going to be much
better off having 10
really solid job applications as opposed
to having 100 crappy ones
more on that in tip number five actually
look smarter not harder as the saying
goes
there's also a lot of jobs out there
that honestly you're not going to want
anyway
and the easiest red flag to spot this
is when you have these insane lists of
requirements 100 different programming
languages
you also want to focus on jobs that a
you're truly qualified for
and b you would actually genuinely enjoy
doing i would also recommend focusing on
a particular domain that you're
interested in
so for instance maybe it's in healthcare
i would look for
data related jobs in the healthcare
field this is going to have more and
more benefit over the long run too
as you gain more experience with that
domain it's just going to make it that
much easier to get
other health care related data science
jobs in the future
but you also don't necessarily have to
limit yourself
just to jobs which are titled data
scientists
you may get the job and you're doing
real data science
but the job title is called analytics
professional
research scientist statistician there
are other examples
so don't get too hung up just on names
job description and maybe your first
phone screen with hr
should give you some pretty clear
information about what the role is going
to entail
so if it's close enough to your own
passions as well as to what classic
data science is by all means go for it
my second tip is to have some kind of
portfolio and i gotta be honest
historically this has been the one that
i've personally been the laziest about
myself
and that's just because this one is less
about actively
chasing or pursuing that job and more
about building an appropriate foundation
let's face it many companies will want
to see that you're truly proficient
so they're going to want to see some
code you've written in the past or some
projects that you've worked on in the
past
and the best way to share this kind of
thing is through a portfolio
best way to actually go about setting up
a portfolio
would be through github you can include
code from
previous project work that you've done
with other organizations
or if this is your very first job you
could just include
code from project work that you've
worked on in school if your portfolio is
a little skimpy
or you're just generally lacking in real
world projects
another thing that you could do is go to
kaggle and work on some projects there
and this will help give you experience
across the spectrum
you can work on things like data
exploration visualization
machine learning etc etc now there's no
substitute for
real world project experience but this
can only help you
for tip number three it's know the right
stuff for the role
but also be honest about what you know
now there's a couple parts to this
first of all you're probably not going
to fake your way into a job
you do need to know things so i'll have
a link
in the description of this video as well
as a card up above
to a video i did on a study pathway to
data science
and this video will outline some key
skills that you're going to need for
data
science in general and also a good order
to learn these things in
but the bottom line is it'll be pretty
tough to get most data science jobs
if you don't have familiarity with these
three things
those are statistics sql and either one
of r
or python and i talk about some
resources for learning these things in
that video
but you do need to actually know these
things and not just
say you know these things plenty of
people will put things on their resumes
but interviewers will generally have
pretty strong bs detectors
so once something's on your resume it's
generally fair game to get some kinds of
coding questions on it
and if you greatly exaggerated your
competency in that thing
trust me as somebody who's been on both
sides of this equation
it's usually pretty obvious you're not
going to be better off by fluffing up
your resume with a lot of junk
you're going to be much better off with
a shorter resume
that's focusing on the key skills for
that position in question
so brush up on stuff play with some r or
sql code
brush up on your stats too i have a
video on how much stats you need for
data science and that one will be linked
in the description as well
but if you get a technical question
during an interview and you don't know
the answer to it
that is actually okay you can start by
detailing your thought process
or at least how you would begin to start
attacking that problem
and that's gonna look much better than
lying on your resume to say that you're
an expert at something that you actually
aren't again if a job actually wants you
to know
50 different things that's not a job
that you want in the first place
now tip number four is an extremely
powerful one
and it's to use what's commonly referred
to as the storyboard technique
once you've made your way to an
interview this is a general
job interview strategy rather than
something that's necessarily data
science specific
but it is particularly powerful with
data science
because you're naturally going to be
competing with a number of people who
are
very tech savvy but they might struggle
a little bit in terms of thinking
and communicating about adding business
value the technique is
you want to tell stories about your
previous work
and these stories are going to have four
distinct parts
a premise the problem the solution
and the outcome in the premise lay the
foundation
and this doesn't have to be much but
just put the interviewer
in your previous organization's shoes
for a little bit
tell them a little bit about the
organization and or the people that you
were working with
next lay out the problem that they faced
all companies have
problems and challenges that's exactly
why they hire people to help
then you're going to talk about the
solution that you worked on so that cool
model or dashboard or report that you
built
give some details on what that thing is
and what it did
finally and this is probably the most
important part
you need to talk about the impact that
your work had
on the business or on some specific
metric
and if you weren't around to see the
impact at a minimum
talk about the impact that your work
intended to have
if this is your first internship or job
ever
granted i understand this can be pretty
challenging to do
but at least with the kind of school
work that you've done before
try to do as many pieces of the
storyboard technique as possible
this will certainly be way better than
nothing but otherwise you're inevitably
going to get questions about the
previous projects and work that you've
done in the past
and this is without question the best
way that you can answer that question
this really communicates to the
interviewer that not only are you a
technically competent person
but you're somebody who can speak the
same language as them
and for my last tip there's a lot of
people out there who are worried about
data science jobs
later being done by robots so if you
want to have that job rather than a
robot having it
my advice would be don't act like a
robot
so what do i mean by that well you need
to do something that
at this time only humans can do and
that's put some real effort into your
application
and to building a relationship with the
person or people
that you're interviewing with for
starters and this gets back to tip
number one
but your application shouldn't look and
feel
like you're just going through the
motions and sending application number
183
and first of all you shouldn't be
applying for 183 jobs
when you start your application
somewhere you want to start it off
strong
and that means at a minimum including a
personalized cover letter to that
organization
explaining how you can help solve their
specific problems
before that you should probably do some
research about the domain
and the company so you actually have an
idea how you can help solve their
problems
you might try reaching out directly to
the hiring manager
rather than just sending your
application in through the company
website or linkedin or whatever you're
using
because only a very small percentage of
people are going to do this
and it's definitely going to set you
apart send a thank you note after you do
the interview
maybe mention something specific that
you talked about with them or somebody
else during
the interview process again you're a
real human being here who's building a
relationship with another human being
and that pays massive dividends when
we're talking about
some other human being making the
decision to give you an offer of
employment
hopefully this helps you get on the
right track towards landing your ideal
data science job
but remember no two data science jobs
are exactly the same
and there's going to be tons of jobs out
there that you're just not going to get
no matter what
or that just aren't a really good fit
for you but if you do these things
i really do think you're going to
maximize your chances
of getting the job that's right for you
so thanks for watching this video
if you enjoyed it once again hit that
like button and also let me know down in
the comments below
how you got your data science job then
i'll see you all in the not so distant
future
until then richard on data